-- [Woman] When you aren't a
first mover in an industry,
like Wine Library TV was, or a
social channel like Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter which all have
so many people on them now,
how do you go about
breaking through the noise?
- Talent.
(audience laughter)
- Some of the
questions will be short.
- You know why, (laughs),
you know why I'm excited?
I'm excited because I have a
lot of respect for this room.
There's a lot of
talent in this room.
Just 'cause you weren't first,
doesn't mean you can't be best.
Now remember,
best comes in two-fold.
It's why I made that point.
If you're actually great at
what you do for a living,
that's only part of it.
You have to be great
at communicating it
in the way it's
communicated today.
You have to understand angles
and pictures or what works in
video or how to use hashtags to
be discovered when nobody
knows who you are.
They both matter but shouldn't
you put in the work if
you get the benefit?